so I'm half-japanese 3/8 Mexican and 1/8
Filipino I am half Japanese half Italian
I'm pretty black how much of your
identity is based on what you are from a
racial standpoint and to think that
could all be not what you thought it was
if it turns out that I'm not Italian or
not Japanese you're gonna blow my
[ __ ] mind I just it's gonna give me
an excuse to try more foods because I'll
be like boom represent my country I'll
go eat this weird food with this blood
sausage I obviously don't really know
much about my ancestry so I think it'll
be really interesting
basically the spectrum of like what
blackness can be I am the ultimate black
person
I guess I have to spit into this tube
and then it's gonna be sent to a lab
spit to film wine that's a big-ass vial
I've to spit - right here oh I'll
honestly like don't overdo this how do
you do
why tend to use my mouth listen I'm
tired
Oh
oh my god ah I hate spit there's food in
there tell me where I'm from and now we
just wait like six to eight weeks or
something for it to come I am a genetic
counselor and I work at 23 me and today
we'll be going over some ancestry
results you ready to go uh oh I'm ready
overall 50% AC Asian and Native American
and then when you look at that it's
forty nine point six percent Japanese
and the other forty nine point seven
percent European southern European
Italian 31.7% Italian they couldn't say
that I was conclusively half Italian
based on the results and then the rest
is broadly southern European which
doesn't necessarily mean that it's not
Italian but you know what though it's
like with white people it's like they
all think they're Italian there's like a
bunch of random [ __ ] up there I mean I'm
gonna say I'm half Italian cuz my
grandpa will freak out if I don't the
regardless of like what the genetic
breakdown is like being an
italian-american is something that's
like bigger than blood so this is
showing you that you are 99.9 percent
European Wow and it looks like 36
percent British or Irish 20 percent or
so
French and German
90% Scandinavian I'm not like shocked by
that but I have I've never been like oh
I'm part Scandinavian I feel like I just
learned that I'm a basic white girl not
that exciting
literally 99.9% European so let's see
ninety-nine point seven percent European
so yeah 57 percent Eastern European 26%
North Western European and then just
half of one percent partition Irish
11.6% broadly European where we really
just can't dig down any further okay
yeah that scans I'm just a basically
just a white guy I'm a little
disappointed I thought I might be
something cool I'm just a white guy I'm
actually like super nervous
71 point nine percent East Asian and
Native American 51 percent Japanese 51
percent that's a fifty one point one DNA
guys it's crazy how possible is Jurassic
Park better Europe eat what the [ __ ]
wait a second where's where's the Mex
Mexican in this when I saw that the
screen said no Mexican on it I freaked
out a little bit
holy [ __ ] it is act like completely not
there there's not a stretch of DNA for
Mexican like the population of Mexico is
made up of other populations Aaron
pretty much told me that the 23.2 South
European and then evenly knows six point
whatever a Native American could be
inferred to be Mexican I mean they can't
be conclusively said that it is Mexican
but it can't be said
not do you think you'll share that with
your family so when I tell him like hey
Dad you know as Mexican as you thought
he's going to be like [ __ ] son
I like how dad's talk to kids and as for
the one a Filipino 10% said I was from
Southeast Asia in Southeast Asia is the
Philippines I would definitely recommend
this for people who are multi-ethnic
like me and uh yeah you may find out
some crazy truth and I can't stop
rubbing my hands um we can see that
you're ninety seven point five percent
sub-saharan African so you can see the
majority is West African that makes
sense my dad's Nigerian but my mother
side of the family is from the Caribbean
other than Native Americans for example
there's really no one who's from the
United States yeah right yeah so the
Caribbean is kind of similar if it's an
area where everybody has come from
somewhere else
got it so we can also see that there is
some European ancestry as well
one-fiftieth yeah I'm gonna tell
everyone I really enjoyed the whole
experience I think it's really
interesting to find out the unique
things that make you you like down to
like your DNA this must be a very
exciting for people from a culturally
diverse background I didn't even notice
that 1.5% West African which is crazy us
white people we got enough excitement
I've never really thought ancestry as a
catalog of boning throughout history
combination of boning and migration I
just wanted to hear you say boning
that's really the only guy was gay